I have to be honest I don't know what to
do the technology is getting in the way
of cooking okay welcome back to chef's
out of water I'm Alexis your chef who is
always up for a challenge that's why
I've taken to the internet for you to
decide what I should cook with next at
the end a surprise guest will come on
and they'll have to guess what I use to
make the meal I don't know who I'm
cooking for and they don't know what I'm
using so let's see what's next okay okay
these are like the most basic rice
cookers on the planet but this feels
fine you know if I could make it work
with a blender I think I can make it
work with a rice cooker
of course I've used a rice cooker to
make rice before but never anything else
I've got a lot of questions do I get
research Yeah right
so it turns out people make all sorts of
things with rice cookers there's cakes
there's curries they're sauces I feel
like there's a lot of possibilities here
little rice Cup some spoon steamer I
think this is gonna be really
interesting that I only has two features
which are cook and warm if I can get the
bottom heat it and use it to saute
things the world is my oyster I feel
like I'm ready to go
my confidence level today is actually
like an 8.5 am I gonna kick myself for
saying that I'm gonna start off with
dessert I'm going to try to make a
chocolate cake today I think the first
thing I need to do is put it on there's
not really an on or off button it's just
plugging it in which feels pretty
dangerous no idea how long it takes to
preheat but I'll let that go
I've got some room temperature butter
brown sugar white sugar eggs
Vennela I'm gonna add some yogurt which
I know feels a little out there but it's
just adding more fat flour cocoa powder
baking powder this is all very standard
again this is all gonna be by hand
because I'm not allowed to use anything
else rice cookers are basically steam so
it'll be more like a steamed cake than a
baked cake I'm hoping it can be really
light and fluffy but I don't know what
temperature this gets to I don't know
how consistent the heat is so it all
feels a bit vague cake ready I'm gonna
grease this down but to prevent a
sticking that I'm gonna put parchment on
the bottom too fancy trick time to get a
perfect circle take a piece of parchment
bigger than your surface fold it over
like yes and then you put it over your
bowl and you just cut like this circle
the pot is hot so cake batter in the
rice cooker this feels very weird
this cake usually takes about 35 minutes
I have absolutely no idea how long it's
gonna take but I'm just gonna keep an
eye on it and move on to my next of
course chicken and potatoes classic this
actually isn't a chicken it's a crush
game hen because this is so small a
chicken wasn't gonna fit inside I'm
gonna try to get some color from the
bottom but just in case I can't get like
a crispy skin I thought doing like some
paprika rub would help give it some
color
we've got paprika cumin coriander salt
pepper it's beautiful great color okay
something concerning the rice cooker has
switched from cook to warm and when I
press cook it just goes to warm every
time it switches to warm I need to take
the entire thing out unplug it replug it
and put it back in switch it to cook
this definitely derails my plan a bit
with in terms of cooking and
consistencies since clearly it's not
going to go for more than a few minutes
we're just cutting some aromatics right
now to add some flavor to the base of
the chicken oh this is gonna be a long
day
this barely fits now it's making the red
sound the chicken smells amazing it
sounds right it smells right I'm gonna
give it a flip wow this is gorgeous
I'm just gonna get a little more color
on oh this is switch to warm to her I
have to be honest I don't know what to
do I can't cook a chicken in a warming
vent it feels like something's wrong
with this machine it can't be me I know
about machines so my chicken got browned
but the machine keeps going on and off
we've looked at Amazon reviews did a lot
more research on the internet and I
think it just needs more moisture so
onions are going in garlic have some
flavor
this cake is cooking it's not fully
cooked yet but
[Music]
it's quite good okay new plan
I'm gonna make another cake batter
that's a little more moist steam it in
the steamer basket put in water below
keep switching it on and off it is
cooking so I think I just need to be
really diligent this feels like a little
out of sorts but my confidence level is
still pretty high I would say I'm at a
seven right now I thought this was gonna
be such an easy one I was like rice
cooker no problem some problems so the
cake looks like it's actually staying on
cook which i think is because of the
water in the base I think for the
chicken I need to get it back to cook
and then cook it with some white wine so
that it adds more moisture it smells
absolutely incredible okay so I've got
my onions my garlic my chicken and wine
it's on cook lid on we wait I was
thinking like do I serve this as a whole
hen like a little cute hen my cake looks
wild but it's definitely cooking the day
started off with a few snafus but I
think we're back I think I figured out
the power if I can just keep the heat on
and consistent I'm golden you know it
doesn't have that crispy skin because it
was kind of like in liquid and of
poaching but there's some browning it's
quite pretty this is gorgeous there's
like all this sauciness garlicky oniony
I'm gonna try to just cook it down for a
few more minutes as long as the cook is
gonna stay on
[Music]
it's divine like you could just dip
bread in this and call it a day
now that my chickens done I'm gonna get
my potatoes ready the steamer basket
worked with cake with potatoes it makes
even more sense
so try potatoes going cake
maybe we should be steaming cakes more
often feels really good that was like
pretty painless
[Music]
looks like my potatoes are nearly ready
I'm just gonna heat some milk and heavy
cream some rosemary I have a whole head
of garlic that I crushed I'm just gonna
get that warmed up so it'll get really
confused and I'm gonna incorporate that
into the mashed potatoes got a potato
ricer which is a tool but it's not a
mechanical tool so I think it's okay to
use it's just like my favorite thing in
the world to do it's so weird oh my god
I love it looks so beautiful these
potatoes are gorgeous if I had a better
rice cooker I think this would be
actually pretty effective because the
rice cooker doesn't have a lot of power
it took honestly like 40 minutes for the
potatoes to put some tinder and they
could have been tender in like 10
minutes on the stove but the result is
great okay my milk and cream mixture
looks like it's ready
oh it's actually boiling damn oh my god
it smells so good if you dumped all of
the milk and cream in here it would just
become like a gloopy mess but if you do
it bit by bit
it'll get absorbed into the potatoes
they're so good oh my god my confidence
level if it's about these potatoes 10 my
chocolate cake is cool it looks kind of
like a brain it's got all these really
weird ripples anyway I'm gonna make a
chocolate frosting and I thought I could
melt some chocolate in the steamer
basket I'm gonna treat the rice cooker
as if it was a double boiler so that
means water in the bottom I also have
mini chocolate chips because I thought
they wouldn't melt faster I'm gonna make
the base of the frosting while the
chocolate melts so this would be about a
billion times easier with a hand mixer
or a stand mixer but you know the drill
got really soft butter Fenella little
bit of cream oh god this is gonna be a
pain oh no I'm gonna take my cold cake
and I'm gonna cut out three mini cakes
and kind of make like a mini chocolate
chocolate I'm gonna make a mini
chocolate layer cake okay if I stack
three of them that looks absolutely
crazy but I could cut them in half and
do thinner layers hey I can make a four
layer cake this is so fun the chocolates
good it's only right to try the frosting
with it
[Music]
this looks ridiculous
Laura looks crazy but go big or go home
I think I'm gonna lean into the rustic
look and put some berries around it to
serve finally a dish that makes sense
for a rice cooker I'm going to make
mussels in white wine super-easy
mussels are in so many fancy restaurants
I think it's definitely something people
associate with a higher price tag but
the whole joke is that mussels are
actually super inexpensive they're one
of the most affordable seafood options
and they're so easy to make I thought I
would make the broth in the base and
then put the mussels in the steamer
basket on top onions garlic pepper
flakes white wine
I want the alcohol to be cooked out of
this and just have the flavor of the
wine you don't need much to give mussels
such an incredible flavor
the taste sets are better like mussels
that would be so sad my broth is ready
I'm just going to add the steamer basket
right on top let's cook them until they
open so it should be a few minutes
it's a moment of truth
wow they're so pretty
oh this broth looks so good I just added
some lemon adding parsley it looks
absolutely perfect can I be the taste
tester I'm so excited
honestly confidence level 10 I'm ready
hi I'm Ryan I'm a video producer at
BuzzFeed I make branded content my
favorite food is sushi
my least favorite food is my mother's
Brussels sprouts I cook out of necessity
I don't cook for pleasure like last
night I had plain chicken and flame
pasta and I ate it in the dark alexis
has made a three-course meal for me with
a mystery appliance I don't know what
the appliance is but I'm going to try
and guess okay you know what
bring them in such a treat hi I'm a tree
you're a tree a tree are you ready I am
are you I am about a level time right
now so I am so ready ten out of ten out
of ten for your first course you have
mussels in white wine very nice say like
mussels I love muscles okay cool cool
cool that's great they're cooked well
I'm gonna take that as a win yeah of
course of course it's a win great oh god
the stuff you don't you can keep going
okay oh my god I'm so glad you're hungry
because this is a Cornish game hen was a
little smaller over some
onions and mashed potatoes I just can't
talk right I'll give it a try go ahead
mmm this is so good that is
well-seasoned
this is probably like a $30 meal thank
you
whoa so for dessert you have your own
mini chocolate cake what do you think I
used to make this meal there had to be
enough heat to get this crust and like
this it curling iron rice wait you
already did a rice cooker no or did you
did you raise a bathtub when you said
rice cooker before you were right I was
right Wow does that make this more or
less impressive Oh totally impressive it
ups the wow factor thank you very much
you're so up this is a treat and I'm
gonna go now I'm probably gonna take
some food with me take whatever you want
awesome I'm gonna spill for sure oh I
like the combination cake and mussels
yeah it balances out bye-bye
I'm so glad he liked it honestly it was
really really good like after the
blender after today I'm feeling good and
really confident whatever is next I'm
ready comment below to let me know what
you've made in a rice cooker
[Music]